there is the results of yesterday's
draft the most disrespected figures in
the nfl rodney was chiming in via text
message with some of our picks from
yesterday rodney's with us today rodney
harrison chris sims mike florio wrapping
up this thursday edition of pfc live
rodney your thoughts generally what
names stand out to you
on the most disrespected figures in the
nfl what can i say chris sims beat you
again
yes yes number one it has to be
dak prescott i mean this guy's a top 10
quarterback in the league and
what he's done the last four years and
what he's been able to accomplish in his
you know the prospect of how good he can
be and you still don't want to pay this
guy he's proven that he's a franchise
quarterback mike
and that i do believe that that could
take him to a super bowl
far in the playoffs and you still don't
want to pay this guy this is the most
disrespected guy in the league
i would say kirk cousins is number two
but dak prescott definitely number one
chris
okay good well he gave you a little
credit there mike you know i mean he
said i won the draft but he's given you
your kirk cousin's pick there that was
good
i mean it's funny when you pick a guy
that he has he's disrespected but the
guy picking him is the one that's
disrespecting him more than anybody
uh so i always loved that i wouldn't say
that
but let me just say this guys eric the
enemy was a teammate of mine when i was
um i think i was a rookie in 1994
and i just tell you the personality he
cares about every individual in that
locker room he brings energy every
single day at practice
he's a smart man and there's no reason
why he shouldn't be a head coach in the
national football league eric the enemy
is that guy
but do you look at like i feel like oh
i'm sorry mike
i just i was go ahead chris i mean i'm
with you the eric b enemy thing
obviously i mean it bothers me it really
does
because we saw two offensive
coordinators before him get head
coaching jobs
you know another name that i thought
about like and i had some people like
push back against
like carson wentz do you look at him as
being a disrespected player because i do
every all everybody ever brings up is
nick foles is better nick foles won the
super bowl
and i just think that's not a not a good
argument honestly
yeah carson wentz was a guy that i was
really thinking about and you know
unfortunately he got injured and he had
some injuries some up and down but this
guy can play what he did last year the
toughness
playing with a makeshift uh makeshift
talent guys that we never even heard of
you know this is a guy that a lot of
people disrespect don't really show
the respect that he deserves and i i
think he's a tremendous football player
i think he's going to continue to get
better as they continue to develop
talent around him
and one thing i respect about carson
wentz last year there was a res
a story that that uh was published about
how
you know wentz maybe doesn't click with
his teammates and and
you know there's some things that they
didn't like and instead of shouting it
down he said you know there are things
i'm trying to improve on and i think
last year
we saw the best version of carson wentz
we saw him stay healthy
and effective with a bunch of guys
around him that we didn't even know who
the hell they were
late in the year and they got to the
playoffs so i agree with you i think
that
you know once i think what happens is
when a guy makes a huge splash early in
his career
and then doesn't live up to it we start
dumping on him even more i mean
it looked like wence was going to take
the league by storm before he tore the
acl against the rams in 2017
and he's been fighting to get back to
that level of a sense and i think people
are are more critical of him because
we've seen how great he can be
and he's still not back to that point
rodney
yeah i mean i guess it's all part of it
you know when you have success
early in your career then all of a
sudden expectations go through the roof
and you know people expect certain
things and then all of a sudden you're
able you know they're able to win a
super bowl without you
personally you take that personal and
you say man
this team is better without me and then
you start to question your skills and
things like that but i think
just his work ethic everything that he
brings the toughness to humility
i think you know i think he has a lot of
respect from his teammates
we got one minute left but we never talk
about defensive players when we talk
about disrespected players i just
it always jumps out to me and one of the
guys i thought about and i know you're
all over defensive football and you've
got players that you know most people
wouldn't know and you love or whatever
jedevian clowney i even thought of devin
mccourty up in new england like he's one
of the better safeties of our generation
nobody ever talks about him
anybody on the defensive side that you
feel like never gets credit or
disrespected a lot
um i think clowney could be that guy
because we have a
we have um a league where pass rushers
are definitely at a premium you see the
type of contracts they're getting
and for a guy with that level of talent
for him not to be able to get an
opportunity man is it's just still
puzzling to me that he hasn't
signed a long-term contract yeah
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports